- Today I am not in Germany with BMW
at their Next Gen Event for the launch
of the BMW IX, as we
had originally planned.
So instead, they sent
the car to me, sort of.
This is the most unique
way to do a car launch.
I mean, we're seeing it here,
before anybody else
actually gets to see it,
and then we're gonna 3D print it,
and see it in real life,
but in the palm of my hands.
I went to CES with BMW this year,
and I had the best time ever,
and we talked about how
much fun we were gonna have,
when I would come out
to Germany this year.
And unfortunately, because
pretty much the whole world
has shut down, and all of
the travel restrictions,
I wasn't able to make it out.
But they still wanted me to feel
like I was a part of the launch,
and to be able to bring you
guys along for the ride,
all puns intended.
So since the car was being launched today,
they wanted me to be able to see the car,
feel the car, touch the car,
but obviously they couldn't
send the actual car here.
But what they did send was a 3D printer,
all of the accessories, the
materials, and a 3D file
to print out a tiny replica
so I could actually see
the thing for myself.
They're calling this "The Tiny Launch"!
Like a tiny launch, it's
like the cutest thing
I've ever heard!
So what's even more fun is the fact
that I got to watch this thing be printed.
I've never printed anything
before in my entire life
by myself in 3D.
So the fact that this was my first print,
an unreleased, never before
seen, brand new, BMW IX,
this vehicle design marks the beginning
of an all new era for electric vehicles.
So my friends, let's
take to the 3D printer,
and print ourselves a car.
Now before we get into
this, let me just tell you
that 3D printing takes a very long time.
I think this total project
probably took over two
days of just print time.
(techno music)
We have the model in place.
Everything is ready to go.
We're gonna do a time lapse.
Are you guys ready?
(techno music)
So right now it's sending
the car to the printer.
And this actual printing
process took several days,
from the shell, to the
rims, to the outer tires.
And this type if printing
process that we did
was actually a very different process
than I've ever seen before.
It uses liquid resin,
which is then released
inside of this tank.
And very precise lasers will
etch this resin and harden it,
so it's basically being
built from the bottom up.
(techno music)
The print is finished.
26 hours later.
And then you take it out,
and then you put it in
a very high concentrate of alcohol.
You give it a little bath.
This is so cool!
I wish that I was in Germany
right now for the launch,
but I guess this is the next best thing!
I just saw that they're
calling this a tiny launch.
It's a tiny launch!
(techno music)
You guys think 3D printing is easy,
you think it's like an easy thing?
You think it's just like, you know,
you push print and then you're done?
Spoiler alert, you want
a high quality print,
that's not the case.
(techno music)
So now I need to clean this up,
get it in the curing oven.
(techno music)
Oh, you're wondering why it's dark?
Maybe because this process
has taken a very long time.
(spraying)
I think I did it.
So now, I guess we wait for this to dry.
Repeat the same process for the wheels.
I love my new hobby.
(techno music)
I mean, it's almost like being in Germany.
It's so, it's so lifelike (chuckles).
Can you imagine me?
This is me.
Okay, so my wheel fell off
(wheel snaps in place).
(beep) I am so, just impressed,
the fact that I did not
mess up my first print,
and I am very grateful that I didn't
because we didn't have enough time
to be able to print another one,
and get this video up
for you guys (chuckling).
So a vehicle like this
usually has a lead time
of several years.
But today, BMW is showcasing
their first model.
And it's pretty cool that
we're actually getting
to take a look at this
thing before it's even out.
I am very sad though, that
I'm not actually there
in person to get to see it, to sit in it,
and to just sort of feel what it's like
to actually be in this car.
But I feel so grateful
that I'm still able to
participate in the fun
by getting to print one of
these for you guys to see.
While this very spacious, cozy interior
might look like a place
that you can relax,
this car can go from
zero to 100 real quick,
in about five seconds.
It has two electric motors
that have maximum output
of more than 500 horsepower.
It also has DC fast charging,
so you can charge the battery
from 10 to 80% of its full
capacity in 40 minutes.
A 10 minute fast charge will add 75 miles
to the car's range.
I love BMW's focus on sustainability,
and this car is no exception.
The power used to produce
the battery cells,
the high voltage battery and
the entire vehicle itself
comes exclusively from renewable sources.
There's a high proportion of
recycled and natural materials
that were used for the
exterior and the interior,
and the leather is tanned
with olive leaf extracts.
I talked a lot about the sustainability
that BMW has been doing in
my video that I did at CES,
so it's really cool to see
them sort of follow through
with all of that in this one as well.
The new intelligence panel
has integrated sensors,
a camera, and radar technology
for advanced driver assistance.
This is bringing together
the latest innovation
in the fields of electric mobility,
automated driving, and
intelligent connectivity.
5G, my friends!
The future of 5G is just gonna give us
so many more opportunities,
and this is 5G enabled, so it'll allow
for optimized automated
driving and parking functions.
Now the doors have frameless windows.
The tailgate has no separation joints,
and this extends across
the entire back of the car.
These new design changes are allowing
for increased efficiency and range
with the intelligent, lightweight
design and aerodynamics.
It's made of an aluminum
space frame construction,
with carbon cage.
Now this curved interior
display, we just needed,
I'm just gonna, did you see that?
Let me just back that video up for you,
because we need to see it again.
It's a fully digital screen,
made up of a 12.3 inch display
and a 14.9 inch control display,
and it's a single piece
of frameless glass.
And I just cannot stop
looking at this image of it.
And I've just been replaying
this video clip over and over.
I also really like these seats.
These are also newly
developed with this new style
of head restraint.
There's extra legroom, and there's space
for storage compartments.
Plus the center console kind of looks like
a high quality piece of furniture.
And this little dial, hold
on, let's replay the clip,
it's like a diamond doorknob,
something that I think everyone needs.
Maybe not in their home, but in their car.
We also need to take a moment
to check out this steering wheel.
It's hexagonal, which kind of gives it
this really neat, futuristic look.
And this panoramic glass
roof is also very impressive.
It has the electro-chromic shading,
which is available as an add-on option,
and this is so cool, because
when you press a button,
it'll basically turn
it into a tinted glass
without having to do anything.
It is magical.
I am so excited for the
future of electric vehicles,
and everything that car
manufacturers are doing
to keep improving on this technology.
And I've been loving everything
that BMW has been showcasing,
and I'm even more excited
to hopefully get a chance
in the near future to
give this a test drive.
Until then, I will see you
guys here on the Internet,
and BMW, congrats on
another amazing launch,
and thank you so much
for including me in this,
even though I couldn't
join you guys in Germany,
hopefully one of these days soon,
I will see you guys
all again in real life.
(slow jazz music)
(beep)
I'm trying to get you out here, bud.
Hope I can get you out by the
time they launch this vehicle,
'cause at this rate (sighs) I don't know.